five days you're wondering what happens  now  the Illuminati will see you Stephen  something  [Music]  forever  we will see what kind of doctor strange  you are  Marvel Studios Doctor Strange adpg-13 a  seed premium Arch formats in IMAX only  theaters Friday Stephen Strange  [Music]  the Illuminati will see you now  see what kind of doctor strange you are  waffles to your doctor strange bdp-13  you opened the doorway to the Multiverse  on May 6th we don't know who or what  brought for it okay I thought one  strange was bad enough  Marvel Studios Dr stray 3D PG-13  stranger it's time  10 days  fair you  for the truth everything you've ever  known that led to this moment  strange the Illuminati will see you now  Doctor Strange rated PG-13 seat in  premium large format and IMAX May 6th